es wird scharf geschossen gerade und das
mitten in bayern
dort üben tausende us soldaten gerade
ein manöver die verteidigung der nato
grenze dabei hatte us-präsident jump ja
eigentlich den truppenabzug aus
deutschland angekündigt und mittendrin
im manöver ist jetzt bild chefreporter
maximilian kiewel der mir auch
zugeschaltet ist halo max was genau ist
das für ein mangel freunde ja hier in
hohenfels trainieren insgesamt 4100 us
soldaten gemeinsam mit acht verbündeten
nationen und von hier aus soll ein
symbol eine nachricht aus gehen die auch
in moskau gehört werden soll nämlich wir
sind hier wir stehen zu unseren
verbündeten und dazu muss man auch
wissen in russland findet gerade
zeitgleich ein gigantisches manöver
stadt mit 80.000 soldaten das zeigt ein
bisschen in welchem komplexen
geopolitischen umfeld dass hier alle
stattfindet und gerade passiert also
kein zufall wohl dass das beides gerade
gleichzeitig stattfindet wie läuft das
denn heute bei de genau ab ja dieses
manöver das muss man wissen läuft seit
knapp zwei wochen wir haben gehört dass
die soldaten die heute hier unterwegs
sind seien eigentlich 8 tagen nicht mehr
richtig geschlafen haben
man muss sich das so vorstellen das
gelände hier ist riesig es gibt weit es
gibt hügel hinter uns ist eine weit
kette beim dadurch laufen haben wir
gesehen dass dort ukraine schon
amerikanische soldaten stellung bezogen
haben und dann ist es wirklich so diese
truppen kommen herr ausprobieren ein
dorf zu erobern andere truppen schießen
zurück und so will man gemeinsam
multinational trainieren sich
aufeinander abstimmen um dann im
ernstfall gut miteinander arbeiten und
agieren zu können
us-präsident hatte ja eigentlich den
truppenabzug angekündigt das sieht er
jetzt ganz anders aus was ist denn
daraus geworden
ja das ist eine gute frage was man sagen
kann es sollte ein ganzes regiment aus
bayern in die usa verlegt werden dieses
regiment ist immer noch in bayern das
liegt auch ein bisschen daran dass es in
den usa wohl noch keine kaserne gibt wo
die eigentlich hin könnten eine 11 16
staffel sollte aus rheinland pfalz nach
italien gehen auch die sind immer noch
in rheinland pfalz und was man so hört
ist dass das alles womöglich noch
mehrere monate vielleicht auch mehrere
jahre dauern könnte
mal schauen ob und wie das alles kommt
wie wenn es auf jeden fall im auge
behalten
bild chefreporter
markus kiefl vielen herzlichen dank mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bild schau dir hier das nächste video an
und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren